. It is great to welcome back to the program
today, Dr Aubrey de Grey, who is the chief
science officer of [inaudible] Research Foundation,
which is a biomedical research charity based
in California developing new therapies to
combat aging. We've talked to him over the
years a a number of times. Great to have you
back, Aubrey.
Great. Good to be back. Thanks for having
me.
People who, um, I'm increasingly following
the space that you work in. There are all
sorts of sub reddits about longevity and curing
aging and using similar language to language
that I at least first heard from you when
I saw your 60 minutes appearance at this point,
who knows how many years ago it was. So in
some sense the movement is getting more traction
in the terms that you've sort of defined for
it. But has there been progress in the goal
of curing aging?
There's been an enormous progress. Yes, it
was 2006 lower than 60 minutes. So it's been
a long, long time. But yeah, I mean the reason
why there is progress in the conversation,
in the language that's being used is simply
because there has been progress in the laboratory
and even in the clinic and the, the, you know,
the, the, the, it's really night and day how
different things have become even in the last
three or four years. Essentially. The science
has, you know, plodding along slowly but surely.
And you know, every publication that comes
out if just one small step towards a, um,
you know, to, to towards a real comprehensive
solution and therefore it's one small step
in terms of the credibility of the idea. Um,
and really, you know, Finkelstein taking off
the work that we do at sounds, research foundation
has in many cases moved out into the private
sector in the sense that we've been able to
spin out project, uh, startup companies which
have been able to attract good investment.
That's really important of course, because
I've always said the um, you know, the, the,
the, the, the level of financial support for
this work is the rate limiter. There is no
question we could be going faster. And there
are lots of people out there with deep pockets
who are willing to be comfortable with high
risk, high reward investments, even though
they are very uncomfortable with high level
philanthropy. So that means that these projects
that have been spun out and now being funded
at a level, which honestly I think suffices.
In other words, it makes the, um, rate limits
would be the actual Sundance rather than the
money. And of course that's just the first
step, you know, things, uh, such things move
on. They go into clinical trials that we get
even more excitement and even, and it becomes
easier to get money. So now that sense research
foundation, we still have a bunch of projects.
We're not yet at the position of being able
to kind of declare victory and say that other
people can do everything. But we have definitely
been able to slim down, narrow the range of
areas which we feel are still being neglected
by other people and therefore focus more intensively
on them.
So you've previously said that you believe
the first human that will live to a thousand
has already been born and there will be a
lot of people who might think, you know, over
the last 10 years that David's been talking
to Opry. I don't know that we're really closer
to that. Uh, okay. Can you talk about some
of the specific advancements you believe there
have been in the last 10 years?
Sure, absolutely. Well. So first of all, let's
remember how I achieve that conclusion. That
prediction the first place. First of all,
we have to remember that the idea that people
alive today could live to a thousand does
not equate to the idea that within the next
couple of decades we will develop therapies
that completely eliminate aging, which is
what would be required to actually give us
a life expectancy in four digits. What it
means instead is that we will develop therapies
which give maybe only a few decades of additional
life, but they give that eight additional
life to people who are already in middle age
at the time, which means that we rejuvenate
those people and by ourselves scientist's
time to make the therapies a bit better and
give the same people, you know, version 2.0
of the therapies a few decades later that
give them a few more decades of additional
healthy life and so on. So basically it's
all about keeping one step ahead of the problem.
And it's very clear that once we get even
a couple of decades of additional life for
people who are already in middle age by a
genuine rejuvenation therapies, then it will
become progressively easier to stay one step
ahead of the problem. So that's how I come
to the conclusion that we can basically forget
about aging once we've got those couple of
decades. And then the question is, are we
closer to getting those first couple of decades?
And the answer is absolutely. The things that
we can really point to that show that we're
getting closer are of course different depending
on how deep you want to get into the science.
But even at the level of, you know, headlines
in the newspapers, we are seeing very clear
progress. Perhaps the most conspicuous example
is unity biotechnology, which is a company
explicitly working on rejuvenation, on eliminating
a particular type of damage, namely senescent
cells.
And they've already got into clinical trials
as of, uh, less than a year ago, I guess it
was. Um, but they've also been able to attract
very, very large amounts of investment. They
were able to bring in more than $300 million
about two years ago now. And that was before
they even began that first clinical trial.
Um, you know, that's the kind of money that
biotech companies normally bring in when they're
already in phase three. So that really gives
you a sense of the magnitude of the buzz around
all of this in the investment sector. And
of course the reason they're getting this
money is because they're getting good results
in the lab. And incidentally, they still are
the first clinical trial came back really,
really promising. Um, so that's just one example,
but the reason why we were able to spin out
so many startups, so many projects into startup
companies which are not doing as well as unity
but they're doing well, is simply the same
thing that work in the laboratories of the
academics that we've been working with all
this time.
Um, and of course in our own labs as well
has actually given sufficiently concrete,
um, actual results that have been able to
be published in high-profile journals. And
so on that the investors have started to feel
that the time is right. So, you know, he wanted
an example. Let's take, um, um, yeah, let's
take, uh, arteriosclerosis, the stiffening
of the arteries that's caused mostly by a
chemical process called glycation. And the
chemical and molecular nature of it has been
understood for a long time. But actually repairing
that chemical change in the arteries is something
that people had totally given up on. And we
funded a group at Yale University for a number
of years to actually, um, worked properly
on this and they had read success. We had
a first breakthrough that got published in
science magazine, the most prestigious scientific
publication in the world. And that worked
then proceeded, um, with the development of,
uh, enzymes that can indeed restore the LF
fixity of the arteries by essentially reversing
this, um, chemical change and that with sufficiently
impressive that we've been asked about that
I didn't do a company that's in the process
of getting financed. Um, we've done the same
thing with atherosclerosis. We've done the
same thing with macular degeneration. Uh,
you know, so this is, this is happening time
and time again.
And if people want to sort of think about
the different categories of, uh, uh, technologies
or treatments that might someday be available,
do you have a strong feeling about whether
the future of this field is in medications
that are taken the way medications are taken
today, nanotechnology that can do a repair
at the cellular cellular level is another
idea. Focusing on curing diseases that are
more the diseases that one gets when they
live longer rather than the sort of contagious
disease that often significantly limits life
expectancy. Is there a one area that you think
is the area of prior priority here? Well,
that's more than
do with the mode of delivery. And I believe
that these, the way that these, these, these
therapies are going to be delivered, it's
probably going to be rather similar to what
we feel today. Most of it will be by injections,
um, because we'll put, be putting things into
the bloodstream. So, you know, just in the
same way that we've actually ActionAid today.
So this will actually be immunotherapy, uh,
you know, stimulating the immune system to
do things that it doesn't naturally do well
enough. But a lot of it will be stem cell
therapies and gene therapies. So injecting,
um, engineered DNA in [inaudible] engineered
viruses of some kind, you know, so from the
point of view of the recipient, the patient,
it looked pretty normal. One thing we've always
got to remember though is that we're not talking
about curing anything. We're talking, you
know, the word cure has too much baggage around
it.
So I have to be very careful with that. When
you cure an infectious disease, that means
you remove it from the body so that the person
doesn't actually suffer from that disease,
you know, unless they get reinfected. Whereas
aging is a side effect of being alive in the
first place. And we don't want to cure being
alive in the first place. So what it is, what
we need to do instead is clean up the side
effects, the damage that the body does to
itself in the course of its normal operation.
Cleaning that out periodically. Uh, so that
it never reaches a level of abundance, a level
of contamination, if you like, that exceeds
what the body can tolerate.
Yeah. So that's actually, I mean, there's
this idea that that is often repeated, which
is that at a physical level, the body seems
to sort of top out, even potentially at living
110 or 120 years. It's that something that
you, a accept and believe that that's what
it is, that you are working to change or,
or actually rejected and have a different
thought altogether about that.
Oh, it's what we tried to change. You know,
when people say there's a natural limit to
how long people can live, clearly what they're
actually saying is conditional on the availability
of the medicines that exists today. They can't,
we can't say anything about what medicines
of the future might do to transcend that so-called
natural limit. Hmm. Oh, point of medicine.
Just like any other technology is to change
the way that the world is so that it doesn't
behave the way it naturally does, but rather
we manipulate it. So, um, yes, absolutely.
That limit is, you know, the great deal of
noise made about that limit. And I honestly
feel that that's a bit of a problem that people
kind of, it's part of this what I call the
pro aging trans. When somebody does a study,
even a really poor study that who've conclusion
is that it's um, that we can't get beyond
the 115 or 120 or whatever. Um, it'll get
published in really high profile journals
if, if, if it will actually important when
and when. In fact, it's really just hype,
right? So of course that's what we're trying
to change. We're trying to keep people healthy
for a longer period than they would naturally
be healthy for and that will have the side
effect of keeping them alive longer. On average.
What is your, uh, thought about life expectancy,
uh, recently being down a bit in the United
States? I mean, is that even, are you working
in a completely different way where these
year to year shifts don't, don't really have
any bearing on the type of work that you're
doing? Or is that something of concern?
It's completely different. Yeah. I mean it,
you know, of course it's confirmed in another
fan. You know, I don't like the fact that
life expectancy is stagnating, but I've got,
we know it's, excuse me, a large part of why
that is, you know, it's a lot of it's to do
with lifestyle. Um, and sure, that's nothing
to do with what we're doing, what we're working
on. Of course it may have an impact, but I
mean, what we're working on May have an impact
on the, um, limits to longevity that are created
by lifestyle in the fence that once we got
really good at repairing the various types
of damage that the body does to itself, then,
you know, it won't really matter if you have
a lifestyle that slightly accelerate the rate
at which the body is creating that damage
in the first place. It just means that you'll
have to, you know, apply the therapy a little
bit more thoroughly and a little bit more
frequently than if you had, if you were living
the way your mother told you to.
Do you have either a diet, exercise or lifestyle
regimen that is in any way informed by the,
the research that you are involved in and
follow closely?
No, I don't, but, uh, that's not because I
think that such things are a bad idea. It's
because number one, I happen to be very well
built. I'm very, really, you know, lucky guy
in terms of my constitution and whenever I
get my biological age measured in any way,
uh, I always come up way younger than my actual
age. So for me, there's kind of an if it,
if it ain't broke, don't fix it. Logic. Yeah.
People may not go, but you're actually 105.
Um, uh, but the, uh, the other thing is that
of course, you know, I spend my life running
around the world. There's one thing I do that's
definitely bad for my longevity, which they
don't get nearly enough sleep. Um, but you
know, I figure I'm pasting the defeat of aging
by a larger amounts than the amount that I'm
shortening my life. So I think it's okay.
Um, and I'm just being flippant of course.
Um, yeah. I mean, so no, I, but the thing
about, um, lifestyle and diet for other people
is we know that there are some people out
there who have, you know, drawn a short straw
or to genetically or whatever. Um, for example,
people like Ray Kurzweil who come down with
type two diabetes in their thirties, right?
Like that we probably can, um, substantially
normalize their rate of aging through the
kinds of medicines and supplements that exist
today.
Uh, so that's great. But for people who are
already doing, I've originally, well, especially
people like me who are doing really well,
um, we know, I think we can say very confidently
that there's nothing that anybody can do that
will give more than a couple of years of additional
healthy life. Now a couple of years it's better
than nothing. So I'm certainly not objecting
to that. But also we have to remember that
the, um, the things that a person should do
are different from one person to the next.
Some particular diet or supplement may be
important for one person and some for another
because there was minor really, really nuanced
differences in the, in the genetics or whatever.
And it's really hard to find that out except
just by experimentation. So when I say, when
people ask me, you know, what should I do?
Should I do an Atkins diet or Paleo Diet or
whatever I say, I have no idea. I say, what
you need to do is pay attention to your own
body and do what works.
No question about that. Yeah. And then a lot
of fields, even in medicine going increasingly
in that direction of really customized treatments,
even for the conditions that we do start to
have more of a grasp of, of how to treat.
Uh, we've been speaking with Dr Aubrey de
Grey, the chief science officer at Sens Research
Foundation. Aubrey, so great to talk to you
as always.
Thank you.